[Music]
the weekend will be headlining this
year's super bowl
but you might be surprised to know that
he's actually losing money on the
performance
seven million dollars of his own money
has been put towards the production
oh and have we mentioned that he's not
getting paid for the show
but this isn't exactly a raw deal the
payoff opportunity comes in the form of
spikes on both streaming and
social media after the big show for
example
according to nielsen music on the night
of last year's super bowl
purchases of the songs jennifer lopez
and shakira performed during half time
increased 16 fold lopez's on-demand
music streams
jumped 149 percent and shakira shot up
by 221
as for social numbers lopez gained more
than 2.3 million new followers across
her platforms during the week of the
super bowl
and shakira gained over 600 000
typically the nfl and pepsi foot the
bill for the halftime show production
according to reuters last year's show
cost 13 million dollars
this year's show could cost as much as
20 million dollars
investing in the super bowl show should
also pay off for the weekend in 2022
when he plans to pick up his after hours
tour again stubhub says ticket sales
typically rise at least 50 percent for
halftime max
in the last five years the weekend has
earned more than 205 million dollars
pre-tax
including 92 million dollars in 2017 the
year of the starboy tour